si una orden ejecutiva precisamente por
el riesgo de que ya no sea solamente la
corte de suprema de justicia sino un
eventual congreso y senado republicano
que según el presidente pues pase a
nivel nacional una ley contra el aborto
por eso invitó hizo énfasis en que los
estadounidenses salgan a votar en las
próximas elecciones
legislativas de noviembre
el presidente que se necesitan dos
senadores pro aborto y una cámara de
representantes también que apoye el
aborto que esta es la manera más rápida
de poder pues es proteger el aborto en
eeuu dice que de elegir una mayoría
demócrata en la cámara de representantes
y también dos senadores demócratas pro
abortos en el senado se firmaría una ley
para proteger el aborto a pesar de la
decisión de la corte suprema de justicia
en esta orden ejecutiva le pide al
departamento de justicia que protejan a
las mujeres que quieran viajar de un
estado al otro pide también que se haga
todo lo posible para proteger el acceso
a
anticonceptivos pide también 1
un punto muy importante que él mencionó
el presidente es la ley para y esta
orden ejecutiva para proteger los datos
de las personas que en sus buscadores
tratan de encontrar métodos para
anticonceptivos o acceso al aborto
muchas empresas están tratando de
acceder a esos datos para después
venderlos a grupos extremistas o a
gobiernos republicanos conservadores que
después pueden hacer algo para atacar a
estas personas entonces lo que dice el
presidente es proteger estos datos y
hacer una fuerza de tarea va a crear una
fuerza de tarea precisamente para atacar
a las empresas de datos que venden esta
información privada de los
estadounidenses y de las mujeres que
quieran acceder al aborto